could a potential ps5 price hike
actually happen plus exciting steam deck
news against an impact 3.0 teas and new
updates to the analog pocket on today's
gamespot news
the playstation 5 is flying off store
shelves but
due to supply chain issues and other
factors the system has not been able to
match the sales success of the
playstation 4 thus far sony's latest
earnings briefing shows that the ps5's
lifetime has reached 21.7 million units
since launch in november 2020. the
playstation 4 by comparison reached 25.4
million units after its first seven
quarters on the market during a call
with investors sony was asked about a
potential ps5 price increase something
the company has done in japan with other
products including speakers headphones
and cameras due to various factors
according to vgc's translation of
comments made by cfo hiroki to toki sony
isn't prepared to comment on the
possibility of a ps5 price hike quote
about a potential price increase for the
ps5 at this point in time there is
nothing specific i can share with you
about prices the executive said while a
price increase would be an unprecedented
move for a console we did just see this
happen with the meta quest 2 which it
itself is getting a 100 price hike in
august if you've been struggling to get
your hands on a playstation 5 and have
been eyeing a steam deck some great news
from valve the company put out a
statement that it will be able to meet
demand sooner than estimated and that
anyone with a current reservation will
be receiving their handheld by the end
of the year quote as of today we've
updated the reservation windows and
everyone who's currently in the
reservation queue will get their steam
deck emailed this year many customers
who are in the quote q4 or later window
have been bumped up to q3 which is july
to september and everyone else is now
solidly in the q4 october to december
window the statement reads it goes on to
say that if you place a new order for
the device your reservation will
currently be for q4 but that eventually
reservations will spill into the first
few months of 2023 a game that may one
day get official steam deck support is
genshin impact which has teased its next
massive update 3.0 including the new
location sumeru the t showed off
numerous new companions many of which
had been previously leaked but now have
official confirmation sumero is the
fourth major region of tevat players
will get to explore following monstat
lyu and inazuma this is the region that
worships the god of wisdom and is
associated with the element dendro the
long-awaited ability that players will
finally be able to acquire in the update
more details at a link in the
description thought we were done with
hardware news think again the analog
pocket is getting some great updates as
well analog pocket is getting an osv 1.1
beta update today the new os features a
new game detail screen 128 memory slots
for specific game cartridge types new
docs support and a new developer program
called open fpga fpga which stands for
field programmable gate arrays can copy
other chips like snes or nintendo 64
chips which analog pocket is now opening
up to third-party developers to help
with the preservation of games memories
in the osv 1.1 beta are basically save
states there are 121 such slots game boy
game boy color game boy advance and game
gear in coming updates each save state
will display a screenshot of where you
are in the game making it easier to
differentiate between separate saves
more details on the analog pocket update
in a link in the description and that is
it for today's game spot news thank you
so much guys for joining me this week
devonta will be your host come monday so
he will see you right here at gamespot